it's not a game yeah it's meaningful
it's full of love it's full of love and
game
game like activity it's not game okay
speaking of game would you guys like to
challenge each other in a squid game
all right but do at the stand not to
stand this was a simple one it's our own
version is it coveted friendly because
it's a question this game is called the
thing is is that or the thing is is this
and you're going to be asked a question
and you have to pick
either of the answers okay
let's go basically i would like to
appreciate what are what are the stakes
though the mistakes are
the other person has to put their nose
in the other person's butt okay for a
long period we already did that okay
what would you like to do then because i
think the butt thing is
i don't think i think kalala's
perspective is the better end of that's
because i'm fully like
nasty
that's why i want to put the stakes more
on her so she really has to win my butt
is so nasty right now do you know that's
how the chinese test for kovid right
they swipe the ass that's how i'm going
to get a full viral video yeah yeah i
don't know we should do this during
clover
okay don't sniff the butt then how about
this
let's go back let's take it old school
let's do thwacks
wax okay they'll do the wax i'll do ten
or five how hard are they twenty jesus
god but these kind of twerks on the head
uh-huh or the head
or it's just here yeah that's one all
right all right but i'm gonna if it's
her i'm gonna go easy oh that's so sweet
but you don't have to i wanna
come on i don't know how about the next
dinner you go to the person has to cover
a two thousand dollar dinner okay
they're two great you have to find wait
can we
all right the first one here we go
snails can sleep for up to three months
or three years go ahead
and you both have to choose your answer
and george keep tally wait wait we're
gonna have we're gonna have seven
questions three years three months
okay i should know this i'm a slug but
i'm not i'm wrong the answer to that is
snails
can sleep up to three years whoa
how many points for bobby
i was too busy writing down names who
won that one bobby bobby okay all right
that's one gilbert that's one okay
what what do we what if we choose the
same thing
that's fine but look like now you're up
once now you're already ahead
so just to choose the same thing as her
every time
you could do that that's a good one
that's a good strategy
whoever's ahead has to go first okay all
right okay here we go
prayer doc pray your dog prairie dogs
kiss to show affection or to identify
each other identify each other i go i
identify each other
the answer is identify each other wait
hang on sweetie do you think that if we
made out like if i was in a lineup that
you would identify my kiss
i would identify yours for sure because
you're just like what's so specific oh
he's just like
like tonguing down hard european go
ahead
so that's
one zero still houseflies buzz in d or f
key
yeah try it
try to find it
[Music]
d
kalala
well i'm gonna say i'm gonna say f
and the answer is
f key yes
wow all tied up all types he has to go
first next time though he does yeah
question number four okay a honeybee can
flap its wings 200 times per second
or 400.
i'm gonna go with 200.
and we're forgetting the uh the answers
must be in the the thing is is 200 the
thing is
the thing is the thing is is 200 as well
yeah okay
and it's very smart strategy it is 200.
400 is insane that's ridiculous it's
ridiculous it's probably faster than
that yeah yeah i don't know in a second
yes that's insane
bats always
turn left or right when leaving a cave
oh my god the thing is is what it is
the thing is this is left
you know what i really want to say the
same but i want to get ahead so justin
is right
and the answer
goes to bobby
[ __ ]
says i'm a head's left the thing is left
all right
all right guys number six the hashtag
symbol is technically called a
nerumogram or an octothorpe
the thing is what the thing is is
octothorpe the thing is is numerogram
wow new program kalyalis tries to even
it up and she does not
so thor
the thing is octo thor bobby wins a
point [ __ ] how far ahead is
baby puffin is called a poof
or a puffling the thing is is that what
the thing is is that poof the thing is
is poof
you guys are both wrong the answer is
puffly [ __ ] i had a chance i get a
chance there
all right guys that is it
you have a chance to show her some grace
some evangelical grace right now yeah
and have one more question
and basically that winner takes off no
it's up to you unless you want
that i'm up to [ __ ] point your
[ __ ] or you can negotiate stuff and
say i will give you a chance if you
i'm just saying just where are you going
to eat can you tell me in advance 100
another g
i already spent a g
all right how about this i'll risk it
all with one question but the question
has to have to do with star trek
i don't even know what
i don't have things yeah yeah
yeah this podcast is sponsored by better
help online therapy check out
betterhelp.com belly for 10 off your
first month you guys you know during the
pandemic and also today a lot today we
use um better help in our private lives
because we love the therapy we think
it's a great